barremore starts a new chapter this
morning as host
look at you an executive producer of the
drew barrymore show
she hopes to bring humor and optimism to
daytime tv talk we need a lot of that
her show is produced by cbs television
distribution
drew barrymore it's good to see you and
i wore yellow in your honor
i wore yellow in your honor we're like
two sunny side up eggs
i know i get so excited when i see
somebody that their favorite color you
got a yellow mic
yes is that ours no i brought it down
how did you get that i know what to get
gail as a president yes
yes i would like yellow mike and we did
let's talk about you hello
most of us know you as an actress which
means you have a script
or you're a producer so you're following
words on a paper but now when you have
your own show especially when you're
live
you really are opening yourself up in a
way that you haven't before
are you ready for that are you ready for
people to see drew barrymore with no
script
yes is that scary to you i'm relieved
which is such an
underestimated emotion there should be
more cards in the
hallmark aisle you're relieved how
wonderful is that
yeah i like that um i'm relieved that
i'm
at this point in my life um i think it
was
probably good for me to go to work and
put myself into characters
but i think where i'm at in my personal
life
right now i'm a mom to two kids
um i've been able to recognize that i'm
capable of change
even if it took a long time and it was
messy getting there
i like what you said about the messiness
of life because look at your your life
drew baron we all remember you as gertie
from e.t
love that little girl i mean but you
went through the wild child phase
you were considered a rebel you were
posed for playboy
you've been married a couple of times
yes i mean so you've had a very very
very full life and so and i look at you
now the mother of two girls
mother of two girl who taught you how to
be a mother when you look at the
background that you've had and all the
things that you've done
you always ask the best questions um
i'm curious though because you have when
i was a hedonist
and you know enjoying all of my
growing up too fast or then being an
adult trying to reclaim a childhood
um start businesses kind of have
even more fun um in a different way all
the little
things i've gone through i've never
followed
messy people all the what do you mean
never follow i never
ask advice live my life by work with
or am side by side with anyone who isn't
exactly who i would like to be when i
grow up
i'm wondering your lessons to your
daughters what do you tell them do they
know
who who their mother is they're pretty
sad they do
yeah and they want to be a part of it
all but i'm very protective i'm a total
doberman
i would like you to be you know a little
bit more of a grown-up before you dive
into
being a public person or social media or
all that stuff
and like they come to my work they love
playing
in the commercial i did when i'm talking
to my younger self on johnny carson
frankie stood in and did the lines with
me i never want them to feel like oh
mom's work is like
they don't want that she doesn't want
that for me no come play
but i want you to be kids i want you to
be protected i want you at 13 and 14 to
think
my mother protected me she built this
foundation for me
that is very strong and firm and loving
what do you want us to feel after
watching your show after watching the
what's the name of it again i know it i
never want to say it
elaine bauer brooks who brought me on to
this enterprise
um who is what do you mean you don't
want to say i'd i'll never call it my
show
you won't nope whose show is it ours oh
okay
all right i like that i really want to
approach it a little bit more
cinematically i want to be a storyteller
i would like each show to have
a bit of an arc i would love it to end
and feel
the satiation a little bit of oh okay
it's over i'm glad it's on tap for me
again tomorrow
and what qualifies you drew barrymore to
have your own talk show at this
particular time
you are ready because what
my daughter asked me the meaning of life
the other day frankie
and um she's six she loves graveyards
and she's really macabre and
staying and soulful and i said hang on
let me try and think of the answer and i
closed my eyes and just with divine
intervention
there was only one answer nothing else
would come in
they said frankie we're here to take
care of each other
oh okay so maybe i can take that moment
with my daughter
that it wouldn't have realized was
applicable and carry that into this show
it isn't my show it's not for me i want
to put everything in it i believe when
you make it personal
everything gets better yep i do too but
it's
about you it's this is for
everyone else and i'm happy to be the
ringleader of this wonderful delightful
yellow sunshiny circus we want to put in
that does have a lot of different acts
and feels and tones drew barrymore thank
you thank you very much cheering you on
the drew barrymore show premieres today
on local stations around the country
okay
i love you i'm so happy to be here thank
you everyone for having me